hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and in this video we are
going to talk about the basic 15
clothing essentials format so let's not
waste any time let's get it into the
video
hey if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and click the
notification belt so you won't miss any
of my other videos now we're going to
talk about 15 basic clothing essentials
for men and if you watch the video until
the end I'll give you a bonus one as
well so let's start with the first one
a white and black button-down shirt
there is very little that won't go with
a white button-down shirt you can wear
it with a suit or with a crewneck jumper
if you want a more casual look I
personally like to wear it with chinos
and then I roll up the sleeves as well
for a cooler look now the black
button-down shirt stream's style and it
is perfect for a night out
[Music]
the crewneck jumper is a perfect piece
for winter and a future piece in summer
I personally like the navy blue color a
little bit more because it can be worn
with pretty much everything a black or
petrol blue suit if you wear a suit to
work you should always own more than one
now if you're not sure where to start I
personally prefer a petrol blue single
breasted suit because it really does
look great black or brown Chelsea has
suede boots
now these boots they never go out of
style they are very comfortable look
stylish and can be worn throughout the
whole year a good pair of white sneakers
they're my favorite wear because of
comfort style and they will go with most
of the outfits in your closet just make
sure that you keep them white good
quality white black and navy blue
t-shirts yes the white color is actually
my favorite as you can see a
good-quality white t-shirt will fit in
with everything you own if you buy a
t-shirt try to invest in something cut
from a high cotton and you probably know
that lower quality t-shirts suffers
greatly if you put them in the washing
machine and just make sure when you do
buy a t-shirt get the crewneck
if you're not sure where is the best
place to buy some then I'll add my
favorites in the video description down
below alright that bomber jacket now the
bomber jacket is always stylish and
relevant throughout the whole year in my
opinion a simple slim fit jacket and
dark color is the best monk strap shoes
now these are one of my favorite made
popular by the one and only James Bond
it is mainly a dress shoe and that is
all that I will personally use it for it
but there's also a lot of people that
wears it with a Jean and a denim jacket
and that's also perfectly fine
no show socks or hidden socks guys this
is very important to keep away those
smelly odors from your feet and the
sweat the sukkah style looks great in
summer but you got to use these sophism
a good quality leather jacket now for
most of you that's been following me for
a while know that one of my most
favorite jackets to wear is a leather
jacket it's even in my logo as well why
because a leather jacket will never ever
go out of style it can be dressed up or
down and it will generally last you a
lifetime
check out my best options in a video
description down below Europe
good quality slim fit black and blue
jeans jeans are very versatile and they
can go really well with almost
everything that you've got in your
closet jeans are timeless and easy to
dress up or down slim fit chinos they
are very good alternative to jeans so if
jeans are not really your thing you can
go for slim fit chinos I use them all
the time I personally love chinos
because they look great in casual and
smart clothing styles now I personally
like to wear them with just a basic
white t-shirt just for a nice casual
look our coats and pea coats you will
need a really good-quality coat to make
you look sharp and timeless in winter
and winter the coat is mostly the first
thing people see so wearing a good coat
that is not too boxy or too long he's
very important in some of my other
videos there's been a lot of you guys
have asked me hey Daniel what is that
coat you're wearing anyways the nice P
coat I'll add it for you in the video
description so you can check him out as
well
a good quality timeless watch nothing
out there can complement a good outfit
as much as a good quality timeless watch
can so when you go out to buy a watch
invest in the timeless watch it will
last you for years to come
I've out of my top three picks for you
in a video description below
a good belt your best genes need a good
stylish belt that fits in with it but
don't go too far especially those belts
are the big buckles you know they don't
look good unless you're a cowboy then
it's fine but you only need two basic
belts a good black one and a brown one
all right now the bonus one is
sunglasses every guy needs a good pair
of quality sunglasses now when it comes
to style you need to focus on the shape
of the glasses now if you're not sure
let me give you one basic rule if you go
out and buy sunglasses this the shape of
the glasses needs to be the opposite
shape of your face for example if you
have our own face it is generally better
to buy sunglasses with a rectangular or
square kind of shape and then if you're
not sure which on glasses to get it and
not sure about your face shape there are
two type of glasses that generally looks
better with most kind of face shapes
they are the aviators and a pair of
black Wayfarers I'll add them in a video
description so you can check them out
and a few other ones as well and that's
it guys thank you so much for checking
out this video if you liked it give it a
thumbs up subscribe and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]